ma sono io cioè l'obiettivo sto
diventando la palla davvero vediamo se
sono palla ragazzi buongiorno scusate se
cosa posso prepararmi un toast per il
pranzo
un giorno mi piacerebbe diventare un
brano fuoco ma per ora posso solo aiuta
ricercando le ricerche di cambio miseria
un catalogo gli occhiali ha speranza di
salvare questo viso dicevo sto per
uscire perché per quanto possa sembrare
uno scherzo in realtà veramente
gianmarco mi ha trascinato nella
scrittura di una canzone e oggi chi è
sto veramente lavorando una canzone in
realtà trascinato da gianmarco e da
marco però sono molto contento ora dal
momento che questo weekend a riva luigi
poi partiamo è fondamentalmente di tempo
non ce n'e oggi ci prenderemo tutta
quanta la giornata per cercare di
mettere giù la demo che per chi non lo
sapesse una sorta di bozza di una
canzone in modo che ciò possiamo
ascoltare mentre siamo lontani e capire
che cosa ci piace e cosa non ci piace
naturalmente non possiamo far sentire
nulla sia perché vogliamo fare una
sorpresa carina è vivo e sia per altri
motivi che mi hanno spiegato comunque
devo scappare perché andare a prendere
il rigo che sta senza macchina odio
tutti
aspettate un attimo prima di andarsene
lì qualcuno sta crescendo va bene ecco
che succede qui c'è un giallo vicino a
centrare
poi entra entra entra enrico apri apri
enrico cosa non capisci di aprile
dinosauro un dinosauro
mammamia della stirpe dei pronto lunghi
giammarco che sta avvenendo a prenderti
pure lui ma come si sa bene da clientela
appena scritto scendi e giammarco
comunque anche lui sta in un altro mondo
nel bayern ci sar capendo niente è
servono due macchine che cos'è quello è
un pacco per te abbiamo adesso vediamo
decenni è il regalo che ho fatto alla
mamma di valentina è un guido mamma di
valentina questo è il tuo regalo verrai
che carino vabbè andiamo andiamo
che cos'è fuorigioco allora il
fuorigioco
che tipo per evitare che il l'attaccante
della squadra avversaria ti si piazza
vicino alla porta quindi gli passa una
palla e lui ti fa subito colla anche
l'altra parte del campo tuglie la puoi
passare solamente se lui è dietro e
quindi non oltre l'ultimo difensore
degli avversari ma che questo momento di
blog però in compenso abbiamo tutti
imparato il fuorigioco
dove vai a buttare spazzatura dai enrico
abbiamo fatto un intro video che era
imbarazzante sul calcio che non frega
qua sotto posso fare è chi frega del
calcio se vedo anche se con un sì ma del
blocco come sto preparando alle tue
spalle un format dove si parla di calcio
settimanalmente bellissimo forse avrebbe
il tempo di chiuderlo
chi stai facendo ci casca
la donna mora
la debito ne sono lavati c è tutto è
pazzo ok spazzatura buttata si fanno tu
sei ancora qui stava dando da marco
adesso speriamo di riuscire a cogliere
delle cose prima del natale cioè di
incominciare a chiudere un pochino di
cose con la continua dire cose perché
non posso far capire troppo va bene così
abbiamo siamo e di cosa sentino sauro
che sta facendo
mamma mia vera questo gli strategist e
faccio esplodere lo rendiamo
alla faccia e abbiamo fatto un furto
pazzesco l'ha visto il suo sguardo
abbozzato un sorriso amaro cosa riprende
v che sono stato fregato che cercava di
entrare in un post rock piccole boyle è
invece avevate la smart siete entrati
immagino indovina un po troppo indietro
proprio niente
se la star ma stella cadente ho fatto i
compiti a casa non ho beccato il solito
sguardo di scudi preparato sguardi
sorpresi ma permette spettabile questi
dentro questo mondo verrà fatta mobile
quando ti sei messo a fare questa roba
in vasca da bagno infatti ragazzi
vogliano avere un'idea ciclicamente per
apprezzarle
sentiamo il commento del tecnico è una
bella immagine rico per la prima volta è
presente durante le nostre diciamo
chiacchieroni 0 toni pronto a criticare
non avrò per nessuno sa di sicuro non ha
diritto a dare un contributo
la critica un gran contributo è sì
specialmente quelle di gianmarco di
queste fabbriche e infine di gusto il
gusto musicale
questo sicuramente tu no
questo è bastato per fare con la sordina
si col così oppure dare qualcosa non è
permesso
dico ma ce l'ho ma se paragonato nei
commenti di qualche video
oddio al d'artagnan ammazza ben guardati
l'attacco di snor large il problema può
rimandare in i clementini quello che ti
pare perché qual è il tuo primo devono
assolutamente avere i semi
lo scopriremo a breve vai tasta il
prodotto non c'è insieme c'è
non per tutti però non sono tutti e sono
sicuro che le persone che ci seguono
saranno del team nord sen
è grazie al cup il materasso materasso
di pietre
ci vogliono marcia insieme cioè il seme
single disoccupata disoccupata
disoccupati sono stati fatti di compiti
di questi compiti hanno già convinto la
giuria briano secondi pure te ascensore
sono state tirate fuori delle cose
bellissime
al neo melodico
[Musica]
ed ecco che se ti piace abbiamo e
ritornando in 1 st seconda strofa ok buy
mi piace un sacco la giuria accetta
ragazze ok arrivato il momento
finalmente di farvi sentire piccolissimo
pezzetto della canzone dire di matteo
l'inizio la musica maestro ovviamente la
prova si può sfoderare era amici tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
immagini di se veramente questa ma che
si è fatta sentire quindi adesso la
canzone dovrei cantare dubbi ne parla e
basta non si fa niente non uscire così
lo tengo meglio dentro non è andata
detesta la destra sto per perde la
pazienza con tante pezze ezio pino
flaminia fare perché fare quel passo
alberto volta come un ragazzo con tutta
la mia approvazione della nostra la mia
solidarietà ha detto che fanno è
insopportabile non sai quanti nomi
sopporti majesty rizzi a cui fanno
esattamente a fare il panino che
verticali cioè il ministero e di farina
acqua e poi cominciò a far scattare
prima di capito espletarlo che non
arriverà mai
complimenti ragazzi anche tutto il
pomeriggio
mamma mia
dopo l'antipasto di mandarini ma che 61
si vive con l'attivazione di andare in
gestioni piace la panne finalmente
questa che palazzo del bullo saggio
ragazzi alla stiamo tirando degli ottimi
ragni fuori dal buco tipo ce lo possiamo
dire andare da ugo marco dalla caverna
complimenti a diodi saprò lo disapprova
siamo in tanti e ladisa prof loro vivono
della mia disapprovazione del resto
siamo anche noi e inter mila vini siamo
abbiamo a ben stesso abem stesso grazie
[Applauso]
no vabbè linea nasti che i ragazzi non
so se vedete che qua il marco invece pn
avanti più abbiamo energia perché noi li
stiamo iniziando dal ora stiamo
registrando in un'orchestra è vice calda
voce di mignogna
12345678 o una specie di eco che mi fa
sentire sicuro di me stesso mi sento
sono rimondi quanto invitati ai
matrimoni quello che meno il suono della
voce che hanno pensato per immaginato è
bello perché come inno satanico
settimane si dipende da come preferite
se vuoi sentire la voce incuria poco
voce in cui ha leggermente di più
immaginavo però c'è un tono bello caldo
dà voce mi piace è un vecchio pallino
rosso vicino si sono sempre lo so ok ora
vediamo se non è il montaggio però è
sicuramente lo metto in iva
bello cioè
ok il dito adesso voglio sentire come
tra i ragazzi inibito cioè adesso di
dire fuori celine dion se la facessimo
due ottave solo per il ritornello perché
si banche soprattutto da due cioè perché
sai che viene voce ma che voglia dire
pare che avevo mi stavo recando sotto
qui non avevo dubbi che a livello di
metrica al seguente link
il tono di voce proprio farina delle
stesse cose però non mi piace molto ai
siti o giannico iniziato era buona
grazie mi sa che il rap più divertente
che il canto narra guscio che mentire
amara di cremare marra senti questa
barra ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine
del primo ascolto primissimo ascolto
siamo io sono abbastanza casato deve
essere sincero marco the ok quelle
greche stanno vincendo di esserlo ci
vediamo domani con un'altra puntata del
blog maschile pure luigi ciao